الى
احمد جبريل مدير الاسعاف والطوارئ في
الهلال الاحمر بمدينه نابلس سيد جبريل
بدايه اخر المعلومات حول الحالات التي
توصلتم بها بخصوص المصابين
يعني
تممت الاصابه واحده
المستشفى عصابه
في منطقه
الظهر داخل البلده القديمه بالتحديد حوش
عقوبه
من استخراج هذه الاصابه تم تحريك سياره
اسعاف الى المنطقه ولكن قوات الاحتلال كما
تعلمين عند بدء عمليه تقوم بالاغلاق بشكل
كامل وتمنع اي احد من الدخول الى المنطقه
تمكنا بعد فتره من ادخال فريق المنطقه
وعهد الوصول الى المنزل المتواجد في
الاصابه
من الوصول
صاحب
الان يجري
في هذه نعرف مدى خطوط هذه الاصابه
بالتواصل مع اهل المصاب بوضعه
ولكن بحاجه الى تقديم من قبل الطماطم
الطبيه ونقلبه الى المستشفى الاستكمال
العلاج هناك مضرب في منطقه حاره الياسمين
يوجد فيها حالات اختلاط ولكن لا نستطيع
الى الان الوصول الى هذه المدرسه بسبب
اغلاق المنطقه بشكل كامل ومنع الطماطم
طبيه من اجل من الوصول الى مدرسه عبد
المغويطي الانصاري حيث كانت دخول قوات
الاحتلال الى المنطقه اثناء تواجد طلاب
المدارس المنطقه المحاصره فيها عده مدارس
في مدرسه الفاطميه مدرسه جمال عبد الناصر
للاناث فتره الغزاليه مدرسه الفاطميه
كل هذه المرايه في محيط المنطقه المحاصره
ويوجد داخل
المدارس طلاب وطالبات محاول جاهدين الان
يتم التنسيق مع الصليب الاحمر من اجل
الوصول الى
المركز
الطلاب كذلك الامر
من اجل اخراج الاصابه في حوش ولكن
الاحتلال لا تزال
الوصول هذه
وذلك بسبب اطلاق المنطقه بشكل كامل نحن
الان متواجدين في محيط المنطقه هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه في المنطقه ولكن قوات
الاحتلال تمنع من طواقم الطبيه من الوصول
الى اي خطابه في المنتصف نعم
فيها منازل متقاربه ومقتضده كما ذكرت
مراسلتنا الى اي حد يعني يرفع هذا من خطر
ارتفاع حالات الاصابات وربما الوفيات من
خلال هذه العمليه
يعني كالمعتاد البدل القديمه في منطقه
مكتظه بشكل بشكل كامل بالسكان ومتقاربه من
بعضها الان الحديث عن يعني المنطقه متوسعه
بشكل كامل المنطقه المحاصر مساحه كيلو متر
مربع تقريبا هي محاصره
مجموعه سكان ما يقارب 50,000 نسمه في هذه
المنطقه فيها
القديمه جميعا
بشكل عشوائي يتم اطلاق دراسات بشكل
بين الحين والاخرى يسمع
اصوات في في المنطقه هذه المنطقه نحن
كثيره ميدانيه نحن فقط في محيط هذه
المنطقه ولا نت الى المنطقه بانتظار
السماح لنا وكما تعلمي القوات الاحتلال او
استمرت ما يقارب ما يقارب ست ساعات او عشر
ساعات لا تسمح
من الوصول الى المنطقه الان الحديث عن
اصابات الاحتلال العام تقوم بالانتحاب من
المنطقه الطواف
باتجاهها باتجاه المنطقه من اجل تفقد
منطقه التي كانت في محاصره
من هذه المنطقه
الحديث عن اصابات داخل المنزل المحضر ولكن
قوات الاحتلال في المنطقه متواجده ويتم
الان اذا كانت رجع السيارات كلها لوراء
الان اشتباك المنطقه
يعني الان الحديث عن اصابات نحن
اصول اليها وتفقد
المنطقات
المنطقه من المنزل
بعد انتخاب
قوات الاحتلال من المانيا يجري
تسديد المنطقه بالكامل لمعرفه الوضع العام
في
غير واضح حتى الان
الهدف المباشر من هذه العمليه ومن تحاصر
تحديدا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في هذا
المنزل في النابلس ولكن هل اتضحت لديكم
هويات الحالات
المصابه التي وصلت اليكم او على الاقل
يعني اعمارهم او خلفياتهم انا الان
بالموقع بالموقع يجري تسديد المنطقه بشكل
كامل لمعرفه الوضع وسوف يتم ابلاغكم بشكل
كامل